the holiday season is often a time to
spend with loved ones but for those who
serve and their families it can be an
especially tough time of the year in our
series we started this year it's called
profiles and service we spotlight
Americans who dedicate their lives to
helping others now we want to take a
look back at some of the people we
introduced you to this year and there is
a theme women who inspire we went to the
Citadel in South Carolina to watch cadet
Colonel Sarah Zorn in action
Zorn is the first woman to lead the
Corps of Cadets in the military
Academy's 176 year history and Jen
Crawford boarded the USS Abraham Lincoln
an aircraft carrier to meet captain Amy
Bauer Emmitt
she's the first woman in navy history to
hold the title of executive officer of a
nuclear worship we met the Easter
sisters their family's tradition of
service dates back at least 100 years
and we climbed to the top of the
Brooklyn Bridge for a training exercise
with detective tina guerrero she's the
only female counter sniper in the NYPD's
elite emergency service unit that's
pretty awesome
yeah thanks for the great climb this is
like no sweat off your back to do this
no actually I enjoyed every minute of it
what a service mean to you stars are
just to be there to be there to be there
to help people you know
people in a city to serve this city I
tell you it's really important to me you
do it cuz you love it oh but it ain't
easy no our towers time away from your
family and you risk your life every day
yeah
yes but it's worth it well worth it well
worth service just means playing your
part to protect your country and the
people that you love when I was younger
my parents are telling me like served
with the servant's heart and that just
means sacrificing I can always being
grateful poor you told us that your
parents never treated you or your
sisters like girls right our parents
never raised us like the typical girl
you know they never said that we could
do anything of any sorts they never
limited us my dad too like he would just
look at me like any of the other people
and say like you can you can lead men
why not you're the first woman executive
officer of a nuclear aircraft carrier
what does that mean to you I hope that
I'm a good leader and a mentor to both
men and women what a service mean to you
service is contributing to something
greater than yourself
for me it is about supporting defending
the Constitution United States but it's
also about these young men and women
that I lead every day you know you've
used the word being a servant leader
what does that mean to be a servant
leader is to put others needs before
your own I personally believe that
servant leadership is the only
successful leadership because no matter
your decision you are making decisions
as a leader on behalf of others I hope
to be a person of service empathy
kindness because I think those are some
of the fundamental things that people
need in this world right now a little
more leadership a little more empathy
and understanding think about that that
empathy thinking of other people is a
key element of true leadership and there
is some exciting news about those Easter
sisters since we first told you their
story the oldest sister Cory delivered a
baby girl look at this grace and she
goes by Addie and we'll look forward to
finding out if she becomes the fifth
generation to serve in her family's
history and what do you bet what do you
bet I think yes what inspired you the
most from the women that you met well
you know I'm from a family who has
served in the military in the army and
the belief is that are so sir yes and my
sister serves - is it the idea of
selfless sacrifice that that's that that
leadership is not a selfish exercise it
is in the service of other people and
people do that and also different types
of jobs but those who serve like in the
military for instance really do it
because they don't control they're not
home for the holidays they get sent away
it's a difficult job but they are best
people in our country integrity never
goes out of style that's true